Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new marvel fantastic four movie video there's
a bunch of announcements that marvel just made so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just post all your predictions for the movie on
the video we just saw john krasinski fulfill all
of our fan casting dreams they actually did the
thing and he played reed richards in a version of
the fantastic four in the 838 illuminati universe
we're actually getting doctor strange 2 on digital
later this month so i'll probably do some deleted
scenes videos when that comes out but you probably
saw the news that john watts the spider-man
director inside the mcu he's done all the
spider-man trilogy so far spider-man no way home
most recently was originally going to be directing
the movie announced by kevin feige a couple years
ago and finally i'm happy to announce a film
about one of the truly iconic marvel families
in fact marvel's first family fantastic four we're
working on a feature now and it will be directed
by the director of our recent spider-man films
john watts but he actually just left the project
a little while ago because they confirmed that
he's going to be directing spider-man 4 with tom
hollands and daya pretty much everybody's coming
back they're going to be picking up where they
left off in spiderman no way home with the college
arc for spider-man i got a lot of questions during
my doctor strange videos about who remembers what
about spider-man and peter parker now because they
referenced spider-man several times during doctor
strange 2 later in the timeline but none of them
know that peter parker is underneath the mask they
just remember that spider-man has done a bunch of
stuff they also revealed one of the other reasons
why john watts left the fantastic four movie is
because in addition to spider-man 4 he's going
to be directing one of the star wars live-action
series it's going to be called wrecking crew
it'll be set later in the timeline and it'll star
jude law they just announced that last week so we
don't have any footage for it yet so kevin feige
is picking the new director of the fantastic
four movie with the marvel people right now
and currently the leading candidate is actually
you guessed it sam raimi himself that was actually
a big surprise to me because sam raimi is known
more as a horror and a comedy director sometimes
both horror and comedy at the same time like
the evil dead movies or kind of horror comedies
sam raimi's doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness that is a dream come true
there were a lot of very sam raimi specific
moments during doctor strange too like the
way he used the camera the way he used the jump
scares trope is a horror thing but also kind of
in a comedic way even that second post-credits
scene the bruce campbell post credit scene was
kind of an in-joke about the bruce campbell evil
dead movie series like he looks at his hand and
says oh thank god it's over because during the
evil dead series his hand turns evil and won't
stop trying to kill him and it's very common for
sam raimi to include easter eggs for other sam
raimi movies in movies that he does so of course
when they announced that sam raimi was like at
the top of the list to direct fantastic four
bruce campbell was going off like oh hell yeah
please let this happen probably because he's also
hoping to get another cameo scene as a different
character inside fantastic four that would be
funny like a bruce campbell cinematic universe
with him just showing up all over the place from
the spider-man movies all the way to fantastic
four but the even bigger news i think is that
supposedly john krasinski is still the leading
candidate to play reed richards mr fantastic
supposedly the cameo scene that he did in doctor
strange 2 was meant to be a trial run so to speak
just to see how fans responded to it and just to
test out what his powers looked like on screen
just to serve as sort of a trial run for what
it would look like if he used his powers we got a
little bit of him like he stretched a little bit
but mostly it was scarlet witch turning him into
spaghetti and him coming through portals the whole
thing with the portals is just teasing the whole
fantastic four subplot with them traveling around
alternate universes using quantum energy the same
way that ant-man and the wasp introduced quantum
energy the same way that king the conquer who
is related to reed richards also uses quantum
energy to power his tva portals that's why
they look so similar to the portals that reed
richards was using you see it's all connected
all the way through the timeline from king the
conqueror at the end of the timeline all the way
to ant-man of the wasp avengers endgame iron man
what they did traveling through time and then
reed richards now in another alternate universe
it's all about all these alternate universes all
the incursions and the lead up to the secret wars
a lot of you've also asked questions about that
illuminati scene in general there were a couple
scenes with the illuminati they were very brief
they were cool but very brief but when they were
all together if something seemed weird and you
couldn't quite explain what that's because most
of these actors filmed all their footage for
the movie completely separately so for instance
john krasinski was never actually on screen
working with scarlet witch that's why you may
have seen that funny video of elizabeth olsen
taking the lie detector test passing when she
says that she doesn't know anything about
john krasinski being in doctor strange too
i never met this man i never saw this do you
think this man is the smartest man alive no
i don't know him though no i've never
met him you were in the same movie
i've never met him she's coming out
truthful never met him i've met his wife
okay then she was telling the truth there because
even though she was turning him into spaghetti
when she was actually filming that scene she was
acting against a stand-in actor and marvel was
just going to swap in whoever's face wound up
playing the character so it was literally like
a copy-paste situation which is why some of his
scenes might have felt kind of weird because he
was kind of acting against nothing when he was
doing his part of that scene the main reason why
they do stuff like that is for scheduling
like it's just really hard to get actors
in particular dates when they need to film stuff
that's the main reason why they didn't actually
have tom cruise superior iron man in the movie
scheduling issues because tom cruise was locked
up busy filming the mission impossible sequels
when they would have needed to film with him and
they just decided if they weren't ready to bring
robert downey jr himself back they weren't going
to do a halfway version of iron man like either
was going to be something really crazy or no iron
man at all but in the illuminati's 838 universe
this version of reed richards was meant to be like
the full fan service fan casting payoff because
they had a full family from the comics they didn't
mention johnny storm or the thing but they were
meant to be alive in this version of the team
and when i say paying off fan casting theories the
writer claimed that this version of sue storm that
they referenced in the movie was meant to be emily
blunt john krasinski's real life wife i think
the deeper cut in this cameo scene was confirming
both of his kids were alive too franklin richards
and valeria richards valeria existing also means
that a version of doctor doom would exist in this
universe too people wondering when doctor doom is
going to show up in a really big way in the mcu
the reason valeria is connected to doctor doom
though is because she was actually born in the
negative zone in this really weird way and he
used his magic and combination of technology like
he is a character who is both based in magic and
technology like if iron man also practiced magic
and he helped her be born as a normal human so
thereafter she wound up thinking of him sort of
this surrogate uncle in a way that franklin
richards did not and franklin richards is
probably the most powerful character that
marvel's ever introduced in the comics just
because of the way that his powers work he can
create entire universes out of nothing in fact
at the end of the secret warsawk in the comics
reed richards winds up being one of the people to
fix the multiverse like repopulate it with all the
different universes that were previously destroyed
using franklin richard's power in a couple years
ago when kevin feige said the intention was for
them to do their fantastic four reboot movie as
marvel's first family he was actually talking
about the original family not the traditional
nuclear family that you're used to thinking of
when you think of family like kevin feige was
talking about the original family of four adult
superheroes reed richards sue storm the thing in
johnny storm and it should probably go without
saying that the version of the team in the reboot
movie wouldn't be the 838 universe illuminati
version for obvious reasons it'll probably still
be set in present day for the most part despite
a lot of theories about that one easter egg and
doctor strange too there was an easter egg for the
1960s that made people think that they intended
to do the fantastic four movie as sort of a period
piece like the first captain america movie there
was a line of dialogue when doctor strange was
meeting the illuminati in making fun of each of
their different names like what what's going on
with this when he meets reed richards and he says
he's the smartest man alive of the fantastic four
he says didn't you chart during the 60s and that's
meant to be a fab four easter egg for the beatles
but also the fantastic four team was created by
stan lee in jack kirby in the 1960s but basically
they're going to be trying to set up the main
version of the team the main version of reed
richards in all these mcu movies and he'll share
a lot in common with what's going on with kang the
conqueror the tva quantum energy along with hank
pym ant-man and the wasp in their use of quantum
energy a character who does a lot of research
and technology and crosses between different
universes frequently all in service of continuing
this big storyline with the incursions and the
secret wars teaser a lot of you also confused
about the familial connection between him and
king the conqueror yes they're related but they're
very very distantly related so reed richards and
kane the conqueror are kind of like very very very
distant half-brothers so they only share a little
bit of genetic material they already said we're
going to be seeing a bunch of different versions
of kang the conqueror in different movies like
different iterations of the character from the
multiverse it sounds like marvel is going
to use him as sort of the focal point of the
incursions because of the kang multiverse war like
they're going to say that the kang multiverse war
is part of what's going on with all the incursions
so even if kang isn't gonna be the main villain of
this new fantastic four movie it sounds like
there'll be a lot of easter eggs for him too
but everyone post all your theories for this brand
new fantastic four movie in the comments and who
do you want to direct it i'll do more videos for
the movie when we learn more about what's actually
going on there's going to be a couple really
big trailers next week i'm in the middle of
doing obi-wan videos we're also starting the miss
marvel series and the boys series just started i'm
doing episode videos for that too so links for
everything down in the description make sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss any
of those everyone click here for my doctor strange
2 iron man deleted scenes video and click here
for my brand new obi-wan kenobi episode 4 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!